japan was not a major actor in world war
one but it did
play a role right as war broke out in
august of 1914 the japanese were
interested in taking control of german
possessions
and they were already allies with the
british so they
communicated with the british and they
came to an agreement that if japan were
to attack
german possessions in the pacific and in
china
then japan could take control of them
and so japan proceeded to do this in
particular it sieged
it took a siege of singtau which we
already talked about was a german
possession these are japanese
boats landing their japanese troops and
this was actually of
of kind of technological significance it
was the first time that you had a naval
based aerial assault this wasn't
necessarily this wasn't really using
what we would consider aircraft carriers
although they did carry the aircraft but
they would place them into the water
and then the aircraft would take off
from the water as they tried to
take the town of singtau which they were
eventually able to do
by the end of 1914. on top of that they
were able to
take control of many uh many of
germany's other possessions
in the pacific and specifically the
pacific
islands and on top of that japan did
send
some aspects or some parts of its navy
to help protect
allied fleets as far away as the
mediterranean so japan
did play a role here the other
interesting
historical note because of japan's
involvement in world war one is what
came out of the negotiations first of
all by being involved it kind of put
japan at the seat of major powers and as
we'll see in world war ii japan
ends up being one of the major players
in world war ii and it's essentially
going on the other side by that point
but because of its help of the allies
japan does have a seat at the table at
the paris peace conference
and as they're negotiating the treaty of
versailles and coming up with the league
of nations
japan is eager to kind of have an equal
footing with all of the other
european powers and so it attempts to
place this
in the charter for the league of nations
the equality of nations being a basic
principle of the league of nations
the high contracting parties agree to
accord
as soon as possible to all alien
nationals
of states members of the league equal
and just
treatment in every respect let me
underline that
equal equal and just treatment
in every respect making no distinction
either in law
or in fact on account of their race or
nationality
essentially the japanese were saying hey
look you europeans you guys have to view
us
and based on the way this is phrased
other people as equals
and just as a mat just to get a sense of
how much what the world was like then
this was not passed even though the
league of nations was the product of
these very idealistic thoughts by
woodrow wilson
uh they were it did not get passed
obviously the the
the british they had subjugated many
people in their empires
woodrow wilson was afraid that if this
were to be included in the league of
nations it would
have trouble passing getting ratified in
the segregated south we now know later
that the the league of nations wasn't
ratified
anyway and so this essentially does not
happen
and even the japanese themselves they
were eager for equality for themselves
but
as we'll see as we enter into world war
ii they themselves
had a sense of racial superiority and
there were they they subjugated many of
the other people in asia especially the
chinese and
the koreans this is an interesting quote
from the chinese delegation
we are not too proud to fight but we are
too proud to accept
a place of admitted inferiority in
dealing with one or more of the
associated nations
we want nothing but simple justice so it
tells you how different the world was
this is not even
a hundred years ago and the real
relevance of world war one for
japan was it it elevated it to becoming
one of the powers of the world